[Music]
is it magic or is it madness
i've got a confession to make
[Music]
i've never climbed a mountain
never swum in a lake
[Music]
i was in a cave once
i'm beginning to think that i might be
missing something well ready yes sir
i asked the best modern day explorers
take me to the ends of the earth
and they said oh we can go further than
that
three
two
one
[Music]
we think we know our planet
but there's still a secret world to be
discovered
if you go to the right place with the
right guide you just might find a portal
into it
and we need to helm it because the
volcano spits rocks up in the air
as if this helmet's going to do
something
with one of these big rocks
i sure hope you know where you're going
i hope so too
i almost guarantee you're gonna survive
i thought you were gonna freak out but
you just kept going i'm an actor i
pretend for a living
the crossing
that's spectacular this is a bucket list
moment
my grandmother used to say all the best
things in life lived on the other side
of fear
i sure hope gigi was right
oh
[Music]